this video is to answer some questions
par for the royal geographic society
this is part of their 21st century
challenges series so first the general
questions
first the general question so the first
question right up here is will changes
in education in the coming decades be
evolutionary or
revolutionary evolutionary so
evolutionary would kind of imply small
changes uh maybe not so noticeable
changes but then maybe over a long
period of time they they they add up to
a lot or revolutionary everything all at
once
and you know maybe i hope you don't
think that i'm not answering the
question but i think it's going to be
both um you know it's already been
stated independent of education that we
are in an information revolution right
now and i think i think that's pretty
obvious first you have the computers and
then obviously you have the internet and
everything now becomes accessible it's
becoming all that more accessible every
almost moment that passes by
the the funny thing is this is the
information revolution and there's no
industry that revolves around
information more than education i guess
there's other industries that are close
like finance and whatever else but
education really is
about i would say information or
knowledge or conf or conveying
information or or transferring
understanding from one person to another
so it really is about
a transferring information or
communication between between different
people
and so the information revolution should
i guess naturally
the education revolution should be part
of it and it really just maybe hasn't
for a bunch of reasons um there there's
different inertias in place um uh
to to to keep it from changing uh
my my sense is and this is true of of
many things is that when people are most
pessimistic about something that's when
it's about to change in a really really
really big way
that's when it's about to give and i
think we are at that moment in education
where sure people have been talking
about technology education for a long
time
people have been trying to improve
education for a long time but the
unfortunate narrative is every every
every year we just hear things get they
seem or at least based on the narrative
we're hearing the media it seems like
it's getting worse getting more
expensive too
and so depending on how you do it you
know either worse performance at kind of
the the grade school levels or at the
higher education level is just getting
more and more and more expensive and
less affordable and even if you can
afford it and you can take on the loans
it's it's becoming less clear that
you're able to even get the return uh
when you go into the job market whether
you're even necessarily that employable
so um yes i think the revolution is
coming i think it's going to come in a
bunch of different ways i think you're
going to start seeing a decoupling of of
learning from
credentialing so right now the the word
education is even kind of muddled
because it's actually a whole bunch of
things in inside of education you have
the idea of learning and this is what
most people associate with education but
you also have the idea of credentialing
which is you know i got a degree from
here there and then you also have an
element of socialization which is a very
important element socialization
and when people talk about education
it's not clear what they're talking
about most people are talking about
think they're talking about this but
when you ask them why they're willing to
go two hundred thousand dollars in debt
they'll be talking they'll be talking
about this right here
so what i hope to see is that this
actually becomes decoupled and when it
becomes decoupled it becomes actually
more interesting
because if if someone can earn a
credential by proving what they know and
they don't have to sit someplace for
four years and they don't have to pay
200 000
then all of a sudden the learning will
happen in whatever way is easiest for
that person so it could be through
something like the khan academy it could
be attending a a traditional university
it could be learning on the job and
what's powerful that is if the
credential is is done independently from
that then the credential can also become
much more powerful right now you have a
reality where you have thousands of
universities and i'll talk about
university the high school diploma has
become
almost you know meaningless now no one
no one even says i'll give you a job
because you have a high school diploma
they don't know what that even means
they and on the other side of it you
have people getting into universities
that are that don't have a high school
diploma that just have really good
standardized test scores and they've
done amazing things when they were
before college and they were home
schooled or whatever um so what you have
right now is
the credentialing is kind of being done
by the same people who are
doing the learning and so it makes
everyone say well look how do we know
what the standards are at university how
do we know what the standards are at
that high school and so that's what's
making and so it's making that's why
it's making standardized tests and all
of that so valuable um regardless of
whether you actually view them as
valuable but that's why people are
putting so much emphasis on them
and so
what would be valuable is uh if the
credential is just more recognized if
there's a nationally or internationally
recognized credentials because right now
you could go to a regional university
and maybe your regional university or
your local community college maybe it's
amazing at this maybe it's better than
harvard at this maybe it's better than
any university at the teaching part and
maybe its graduates actually
do know the material really you know
deeply and amazing and they know it
better than the the kids graduating from
the ivy league but the sad reality right
now is even if they do
their credential will not carry as much
weight in the eyes of most employers as
that harvard degree will or that
stanford degree or that mit degree and
so they have a credentialing problem but
if you decouple these things these
students who learn from the regional
university could go and prove that they
know it just as good as anyone else and
so uh you know i i think you're gonna
you're gonna see some very interesting
things and i think once you open this up
and people can get the credential and
hopefully that obviously the cost of the
cost of getting tested even if it's a
very rigorous test even if it's a more
rigorous test than what's going on right
now in the best universities that's not
going to cost 50 000 a year you know you
ask a university right now why they're
charging 50 000 a year they'll say it's
oh look at our look at our our
facilities look at our campus look at
our professors salaries
they're not going to say they don't say
we're charging you 50 000 a year because
we're giving you really rigorous exams
we're giving you oral exams and all the
rest and so if you if you if someone but
if you have students why they're paying
50 000 they'll tell you that for the
most part they're paying for the
credentials and then somewhat some
students hopefully for the learning and
then some for the socialization and that
socialization can take can take many
forms but i suspect the credentialing
itself can be done in a better way than
it's being done now and that can be much
cheaper
you know i'm talking in the orders
hundreds of dollars as opposed to
thousands of dollars and then it becomes
and then it opens up the learning part
to
whatever works best and i suspect once
you do that then now
higher education institutions won't have
this kind of um
kind of control over over over the
market and and it'll be very hard for
them to justify raising their tuition
six percent every year and it'd be very
hard for them to they would have to
prove the case that it really is worth
fifty thousand dollars that their
graduates really are performing better
on these credentials than say people who
use uh the khan academy or go to their
local community college or or learn on
the job so i think i think you're
definitely going to see that coming and
i think in 10 years or so you're you're
going to see that shift and you're
actually going to see that um
i think
tuition costs are going to give because
they really can't they're already
becoming so unaffordable for so many
people that i think everyone's going to
wake up at some point and realize that
you know there has to be another way
how important is knowledge in a modern
education so knowledge is one of these
words it depends how you think about
knowledge is knowledge you know fact
information is it per specific
skill set is is it a meta-level skill of
kind of knowing how to learn and you
know some would say it's all of the
above um what i would say is what are
what i what i think are the most
important things in a modern education i
think it's the ability to
be creative i think it's the ability to
kind of you know
go into an open space that there where
nothing is defined and be able to look
at and look at the tools that are
available to you and put something
together that that meets a problem um
and that this could be in a technical
sense or it could be in a business sense
or a market whatever whatever sense and
so i think the most important things
that people should should get from their
education is the ability to make things
the ability to create things and
unfortunately that's the thing that i
think is is completely absent from our
current uh from our current education i
mean one example is math and there's a
huge debate about what the best way to
teach math is and all the rest
but what's shocking is is that no one
ever says well maybe there should be
engineering in in in education to some
degree that's limited by people's
perception of of whether we can get um
you know proper engineering even taught
you know whether we can find the talent
to teach the engineering in schools but
no one ever says because frankly the
ability to engineer and i'm saying
engineering in the broadest sense of the
word not what people normally associate
with engineering i'm saying engineering
which is really and
most people don't normally associate it
as a deeply creative field but it is a
deeply creative in fact engineering is
by its very nature it's creating things
that never existed before and and so
engineering is not something that's
emphasized right now um i would you know
there might be a music class and music
class is focused on playing things but
you don't you very you see very little
composition at especially at the k
through 12 level everything is focused
on on playing things that someone else
has written so the creativity is
de-emphasized in in school right now and
i think that's the very thing that has
to be
emphasized a lot a lot more heavily that
just ability because frankly and this is
the reality of the modern world is that
the tools are going to change the jobs
are going to change the information you
need to know for that job are going to
change but what you really need to do is
that ability to one create something out
of nothing so that's the creativity and
i would say that the second thing is
this ability to kind of
self-teach yourself so look at the
resources that are in the world to give
yourself the the tools you need to be
able to create that thing
the next question if the era of a job
for life is over and we all need to be
more adaptable do you foresee a future
of people self-educating through their
life so i actually i guess maybe i was
my peripheral vision was reading this
this question
um
so yes i think self-educating throughout
life um
you know beyond just the economic
aspects of it maybe being a requirement
now because the world is changing so
fast and jobs are changing so fast but i
also just think it's helpful healthy
from a happiness point of view um you
know just as you people go to the gym uh
you know they they they they do
exercises not because they're going to
compete in some sport not because
they're paid to compete in exercise they
do it because it's good for their health
and they do it because they know it it's
it makes them happy you know there's
even been studies that you know
endorphins get released in your brain
and all of that and i think the exact
same thing is true of learning i mean
you're just exercising a different part
of what it means to be a human you're
exercising your brain and um so one i
think is going to be an economic
imperative you will need to self-educate
through your life i mean going back to
this answer the context is going to keep
changing the only
skill that will really be valuable is
the ability to learn
very quickly and then apply it in a
creative way to create something that
that has never existed before um and i
also think hopefully people will start
to recognize that
self-education
is an economic imperative but it's also
a really satisfying thing that will give
people more happiness than many of the
things that people perceive will give
them happiness like more square footage
or a fancier car
now khan academy related what are your
aspirations for the growth of the khan
academy
so
our our attitude towards growth is i
mean we'd obviously love as many
students as possible to use it but but
our attitude is let's let's focus on
let's focus on what we are producing um
and let's make sure it's as compelling
of an experience for the people who are
using it as right now as possible and if
we do that
other people will find it compelling as
well and those people who are using it
and finding it valuable right now will
tell other people
and so in terms of user growth i mean i
can hope that it continues to grow at
the rate that's doing it it grew tenfold
in this past year and we're about 2
million unique students a month but
you know
we don't want to get to 20 million or
200 million and have a bad experience
our main focus is is keep keep tight on
the experience if you talk about growth
from a future point of view um
we hope to expand the faculty and this
is something i've started hinting at a
little bit but we are
i don't want to be the only person
teaching i do want to teach on khan
academy the rest of my life but i think
there's other people who bring super
valuable voices to the table and so
we're going to expand the faculty and
you'll hear more about this in the
coming months we're also going to expand
kind of what you know the platform that
we have we hope to enable students to
communicate with each other and to turn
really into a community experience and
we just have to think of a good way to
do that and obviously you know expanding
the faculty but this also goes with the
software part of it we want to expand
the content base both the video side but
also the exercises so eventually you can
also find use khan academy as a way to
to to learn um uh to to learn art
history or to learn uh a
chemistry or whatever to actually
practice those things
your thoughts on flipping the classroom
i thought this was fantastic well thank
you for thinking it was fantastic but
one thing i want to emphasize because i
talk about flipping the classroom and
that ted talk and got a lot of press and
uh and the notion is that these these
high school teachers were saying hey sal
gave the lecture so let's let's let my
students watch sal's videos and then the
teacher can use class time for
interaction and that i 110 agree with
that idea um
what we're advocating now is taking that
even further so it's not even a pure
flip it's now every student whether
they're at home or in at the classroom
working at their own pace at their own
time and then the teacher intervenes
either when there's a need to do an
interactive project or a conversation or
the teacher intervenes when they see a
student being stuck so it's still it's
we kind of you can go to a pure flip
then when you go to what we're talking
about it becomes a little less pure of a
flip we're saying look if if a video if
a kid needs to watch a video in the
classroom that's okay uh we don't think
that the classroom should be about
watching videos but if that's what they
need at that moment for that kid not all
the kids that kid they can watch the
video and if they want to do exercises
at home that's great but the important
thing is is that they can fully leverage
the humans in the classroom their peers
and the teacher and the teacher is
spending every moment of his or her time
in meaningful interactions with students
and really taking them to the next level
and then the last question is your
thoughts on the potential of game
mechanics and ict
in general to encourage the learning
process any clear evidence in the khan
academy
so there is this layer of points and
badges and streaks and and things like
that in the khan academy um anecdotally
it seems like a lot of kids find it
compelling we've you know uh
uh
even in the data in the school it looks
like a lot of kids became more engaged
when we through this later on but we're
constantly experimenting with it and
we're constantly making sure that it's
driving the right behaviors that that
that we you know that it's not that kids
aren't just looking at the badges or the
points that they really are getting good
gains and they're starting to enjoy the
learning process itself and so
the evidence we saw really good results
from los altos i actually put some of
those results in a previous video that i
made today so you can look at that and
that's why los altos is going district
wide not clear if that's due to the game
mechanics or do the content or some
combination of both of them uh but we
hope to continue to explore this and and
we're talking to the teachers and
students constantly about how to tweak
this so we can make it a better
experience and we also hope to make put
some you know a lot of our game
mechanics right now for the most part
extrinsic so they're independent of the
subject at hand we also want to put a
lot of intrinsic motivators so some of
the exercises themselves are like games
but they're games that are where deep
subject matter help you solve the game
so this is something that we're just
going to constantly um try to iterate on
it and address and this brings it to an
important issue as you know we've gotten
a lot of press
and uh
you know we we hopefully think we think
hopefully that we are having an impact
right now but we think we're very early
on in the process and we don't think
that we have all the solutions and i
think what is uh kind of the opportunity
that we have at the khan academy what's
excites me is that we do have the
traction that we can now become the the
best lab for really figuring out what
works and then getting traction on that
so we view ourselves we're early in the
game you know in the baseball analogy
top of the the first inning uh uh right
now uh maybe i should make a qriket
analogy but i don't i don't understand
qriket um but uh we think we're really
early on and so we think it's a it's a
very open-ended question on where we're
going to take this we really just want
to be open-minded about
building stuff looking at the data
looking at the feedback and then taking
that seriously and then and then
continuing to
to refine it